welcome to this video playing dreadhead
at this estonia yes I'm right for once
yeah he doesn't have a name in the notes
or he does have a name in the notes
sundog cook from Estonia has mentioned
feeder about 2,200 okay I lost a couple
of seconds to check out the profile then
playing the h3 line again yeah should I
play the exchange yeah come on it's been
a long day need some less a complicated
position yeah here this is the big
parting of the ways instead of rupee
eight black has many options see 697
night a6 guide rope yet rupee eight
probably being done most down solid one
ya ta black usually chooses between b5
and taking on d5 no be sure to be seven
yes exactly and hmm yeah I think Roxy
oneness the move that is played here but
not one hundred percent sure if he takes
on d5 I have Roxy seven and this looks
like an like none can stabilize ocean
and yeah he cannot take on d5
alright so he played rook c8 what now it
still does not threaten to take on d5
this is important because they take on
CA take on d higher and win the rook so
I can probably play this move to connect
rooks
you know if I take now and he takes with
the bishop there's efore hanging so
maybe I could also play rock d 1 yeah
I'll just take a 92 not clear yeah I'm
not so sure what the night is doing on
f3 anyway so I'm taking and then I am
put the night on d 2 let's briefly
consider if he takes with the bishop hmm
now I could play rock d 1 d 7s hanging
okay let's let's do that and not think
too much Luke should be bad yet of
threatening look takes his six winning
material so on he might yeah exactly
move move move it to hear ya i wonder if
i just take if this what is this end
game now giving up the bishop pair which
is not so great but term at some of
course a very weak structure
mium
yeah he falls hanging so I need you to
do something about that if I go to d 2
not 1 i'm doing that now i'm not sure if
this is good it it could be premature
you know yeah come on I'm not sure about
this but I'd like to further simplify
the position and make sure that he does
not keep the bishops I thought rook c8
now and I take play Knight B 3 so that I
have Roxy one and Roxy to with us rugby
too so I have a have a solid set up and
an end game of night against bishop
would be quite noisy with all rooks
exchanged so Roxy once the idea he might
play the check rakhti to Roxy for any
other moved to keep the rock on yes but
Roxy one right get the exchange should
should almost lose so he couldn't do
that okay Ferg all night too
yeah well maybe maybe I should regroup
to d3 this looks like a good idea the
night is not particularly great here
five amateur yeah well are threatening
before now okay so should I play bb3 gym
it's not a necessary move like the
moment really check
hmm
yeah but probably I need to do that it
also introduces this idea Knight to g5
yeah the night is really strong him so
let's see how to get ahead maybe look g7
attending and i might play luque edge
with counter play maybe he had 97 this
is actually am an attack against the
king so look here okay too i cannot go
to f3 this is a problem i wanted to play
okay yeah this I didn't really think
about okay I'm i only have 30 seconds
now I'm losing control here but maybe
it's still fine but it feels a bit
uncontracted check
check-check time warning I don't see any
way to to get ahead here King before
maybe I'm just just going going towards
the pawns check check check check check
check check check black for fits on top
yeah this was a bit dirty but I only I
only wanted to make any moves I did
nothing on the clock of course here why
it's completely winning now is righted
we wow what a week I am yeah well
nothing I can do about that I thought
that I thought that he really was
completely hot plate in this game to be
honest I mean this is just just bad from
from from right from the start and it's
just a question how bad the position is
gay obviously has no idea about the game
and all this position this position is
just somewhat better for white the
computer is actually giving it as a win
already which is a bit much but okay
King III it gives us better you but I'm
keeping in that show and in any case
it's just a matter how much of an
advantage yeah this the computer
actually gives us equal which surprises
me why it is still better here the
structure is just better for bite and
the way it it went down this is so just
just excellent for cat I really don't
see his point
I could I could have played a stronger
in this part of the game I'm pretty sure
to to punish him but then I didn't
manage I only have 40 seconds available
check and this is completely willing I'm
Jack there wasn't a single position
where black was was equal and so they
shall check yeah not really recognizing
what what's going on and now I'm just
they're getting the pause so while hear
it it got just a terrible um yeah time
trap influenced scramble and cannot
really analyze that why this is
completely winning here like h4 h5 I
think the side I even played check check
check check Yeah Yeah right here just
played any hecticness that was available
I've done okay by this kind of person
sir who really a sent those messages
really show that they have no idea what
what's going on and they will never
improve to any point if they don't
really recognize what happened in the
game alright thanks for watching